hey good humans welcome back to odd man
out hey big thanks to Skillshare for
sponsoring this episode stick around
after the episode for a special offer
but for now are you ready for it my fans
they call themselves Swift gays I love
you guys so much why sing to the haters
well when they stopped coming for me I
will stop singing to them we brought
together 7 Taylor Swift fans I am a
Taylor Swift fan I am a Taylor I am I am
a Taylor Swift fan I am a Taylor Swift
fan I am a Taylor Swift fan I am a
Taylor Swift fan one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives he or she wins the entire prize
I was thinking like ranked the album I
feel like you should be able to name all
of them okay my third favorite has to be
1989 my second favorite is the new one
lover and my number one favorite it's
rep it just it speaks so differently so
my number one is always and will forever
be read and then love her and then
fearless my favorite is speak now and
then my second its reputation I was such
a place in my life for that
and then my third one is probably lover
yeah I just like everything it
represents like just just save okay we
have like a few seconds just say the
album and the move on there are seven
people that need to go I would say my
1989 I love Taylor Swift okay I think
I'm speak now and then mine goes 8 1989
and then she was so like smiley the
entire time I was like this girl has a
secret like she's holding something back
like she gave me like Midwestern like a
Widow's Iver I feel like people like
killed her husbands or something he
didn't look like what I think a Taylor
Swift fan would look like like an 18
year old girl basically I mean there's
me of course who's 26 I didn't get to
know enough about him so I'm just like
okay he was a little silence this feels
so mean sorry cuz why we can't have nice
things
I clearly didn't get to talk and look
where I'm at anyone can link that up
facts about like her but her kiddies
where did they come from though
sometimes people don't know the Taylor
has actually three cards what you do but
I don't know the third one's name you
don't know that one's name
I don't do you know where she met her
new cat for the first time I
on the set of me his name is Benjamin
Benjamin Button I didn't know the name
of her cat that's like it was one cat
it's just I was just very frustrated my
favorite song is probably like delicate
I really like that like you can never go
wrong with like a track five every track
five off of Taylor's albums is I don't
feel like The Archers should be track
five oh that is my least favorite song
oh that's that's basic oh I love it
I look I act like I stalk like I just
seem like a Taylor Swift fan like if
anybody's gonna be a fan it's gonna be
me why don't we talk about like
something controversial like that she
didn't speak out when she was like
proposed is like an Aryan princess like
how do you guys cuz I get so much like
crap from my friends for liking her
because she's a successful white woman
yeah and she inserts herself into things
that she doesn't need what just totally
like bull crap right why would they like
not like that like I'm really like
confused right now like that I can't we
were set like your friends give you [ __ ]
or whatever as a person of color it's
like really shitty for people to be like
oh like the person you look up to more
than anyone else in the world
it's a horrible person and thinks you're
a horrible person like so that I don't I
do think her silence was not good the
silence affected fans and you know the
world in a way that maybe wasn't fair so
I felt like I needed to say something
about that it's cuz she I think she's
learned how she can be like super open
and also be like okay you guys don't
deserve this part of my life for now and
how she's so quiet yeah she's almost out
of that spotlight like that's a and I
think she's just really matured with it
oh no this is me so hard I don't like
[Music]
everyone else they were like full like
for Taylor like Ryder died - Kayla had
like a little bit of havoc hesitation I
did not feel great when I got bumped out
I'm just like slightly offended maybe
more than slightly but I think it was
because I didn't completely agree with
the group for the political stuff I want
to know why you two voted for them - I
voted for Michaela - at the end because
whatever Scot first thought I could read
[Applause]
you know about me is I'm a naturally
quiet person like I don't know why I'm
very awkward so it's very hard for me to
like open up sometimes so yeah and the
only reason I picked Michaela it was
because we talked about like not
speaking up and I felt like she might
have been like upset at that maybe yeah
don't like her originally but that's
only because I didn't know who to vote
for and I was like nobody's gonna vote
for Annie
I love Fallon like Fallon was a queen
but then there were definitely times
where I was like this girl like she's
just like lining it up like she's
agreeing with me just to make it
agreeable I feel like at this point we
might have we might have kicked out the
mole or I don't know but I feel like
what I'm kind of looking for it is that
like the way I feel about Taylor is that
she is just genuinely a good person and
she she sends like money to people's
weddings she's I'm like so jealous other
people who go to like her album parties
at her house that's the one thing I love
so much about Taylor is she's very
connected with her we've grown up with
her and like we've seen her go through
terrible things like great things and a
bunch of boyfriends
had a bunch of thing I feel like she
gets a lot of hate on in this industry
is because she's just going through her
phase to try to find we have to talk
about like does anybody have like a
weird quirk that they do and like
they're one of their favorite songs like
my favorite part of better than revenge
is when she goes so much better yeah she
does this thing and she's like whoa so
know every time that song comes on to go
wow really every single time I hear
we're never ever getting back together
on me and my sister collectively
remember from the tour the weed I feel
like we already she kept making like
weird eye contact with me the entire
time like everyone else would be talking
and then she'd make eye contact with me
and go like
[Music]
I'm just I'm scared that's the only
reason I think it was Michaela what do
you want what do you want should we just
go through one more ok what's one more
I was under the impression that we like
had just sacrificed me because I felt
like everyone in this the box was like
already like a really genuine and then
when they kept going I was like no no
just share the money what are you guys
doing I'm already feeling pretty
confident we got them all that's the
problem because they didn't get enough
time to talk have all of you guys been
to you've been to one of her concerts or
performances concerts actually oh the
new year I went to 1989 I got the worst
seats in the world at least you could
hear her like I was like I would do some
like a lot too like we can all buy
liquor like Airbnb all right they'll be
fun that'd be fun you all didn't know
that you were bringing us all together
what's your number one favorite song
would probably be stay stay stay
okay okay I'm thinking of haunted right
now from speak now but I go ahead maybe
like mine are better than revenge Iman
she said it better than revenge but I
feel like it's not anybody's go to it
might be it might be personal I promise
one of the first people we voted out it
could still be somebody standing here
honestly but at this point they did such
a good job but I want to congratulate
[Applause]
did not expect Alicia
of all people you were my last okay at
this point it's kind of corny the hate
today's life because I feel like
everyone does it like I like her music
and I like her dedication I don't like
her as a present she sits like kind of
annoying she comes off as like a little
pretentious or entire it'll like her
feminism it's like used to be very very
like limited like upper-middle class
like not like people of color like not
like a very wasn't like inclusive to
like people who are like LGBT and like
stuff like that and like obviously like
she's making strides to talk about like
stuff like that but I feel like that's
like something that kind of like
bothered me
[Music]
I'm really relieved because I was really
nervous that people were gonna think I
was the mole even though I know I'm not
I'm a big fan I have like a fan a cow
I've had one since I was in like middle
school I have a tattoo I met her in
secret session Oh made like six new
friends like even Alisha despite our
differences it started a conversation
like it like goddess talking and I'm
like that was just really cool like I
made friends congratulations on catching
them all and big THANK YOU to Skillshare
for sponsoring this episode
I think one reason that Taylor Swift is
insanely popular is because a lot of her
songs tell stories and I do believe even
though most of our work is non-scripted
we're always thinking about storytelling
principles so one class of I really love
on Skillshare is called storytelling for
leaders it basically breaks down how to
tell a great story all the parts the
components the art types and even has a
downloadable template so you can get
writing right away for those of you who
don't know Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes on a variety of topics such as
creative writing graphic design
photography and more Skillshare is super
affordable compared to pricy in-person
classes and workshops and for just ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription you get unlimited access to
all of their classes through their
premium memberships and because
Skillshare is sponsoring this episode
you can use the link in our description
for two months free thanks for watching